- When you think of musical improvisation,
the first thing that comes to mind
might be jazz or the blues.
But the practice of
improvisation is actually
a part of many musical
traditions all across the globe.
(drums slamming)
(gentle piano)
As a classically trained musician,
I've personally been working on developing
my improvisational skills
over the past few years.
As you can see from these charts
that detail how I spend my practice hours.
(drums slamming)
(gentle piano)
- All right, do it again,
do it again, do it again
- Today, classical musicians
are know for playing music
as written in the score note for note.
But this wasn't always the case.
This may surprise you,
but from the middle ages
to about the late 1800s or so,
improvisation was actually a big part
of music performance and training.
So why has classical
musicians stopped learning
how to improvise?
(drums slamming)
(gentle piano)
- In classical music,
improvisation dates back
to the middle ages.
Soloists would add
spontaneous embellishments
over familiar melodies.
And the score provided
served as a skeleton
of the melody over which musicians
would add their own variations.
An example of melodic
variation today might
be found at a sporting event
with the national anthem.
Singers would typically add in variations
and fills while keeping melody
and lyrics still recognizable.
Going overboard with
embellishment, however,
is never ideal because it can easily lead
to a distasteful interpretation.
(garbled singing)
(crowd laughs)
- Classical musicians also
improvise accompaniments
to melodies.
In fact, the first record of improvisation
in Western music comes
from ninth century writings
that detail how to add counter melodies
to Gregorian chants.
Later, during the Baroque era,
this type of improvised accompaniment
became what is called basso continuo.
They used a kind of music
notation called figured base
which provides a baseline
along with symbols
that indicate what intervals to use,
chord suggestions, and types of voicings.
So a musician, say a keyboardist,
would take this information and would
improvise with and over the baseline.
Probably the most widely known example
of improvisation in classical
music is the cadenza.
If you're playing a Mozart
concerto back in the day,
towards the end there's
always a point where
the harmony reaches a
peak then everyone stops
and the pianist or
whatever instrumentalist
will do a solo, basically on
the themes from the main parts
and traditionally that was all improvised.
(piano music)
- Yeah
- That was your theme.
Maybe you would
(piano playing)
So we're in G major.
That's the orchestra,
the connector goes okay
(piano playing)
- Okay, question, is this
improvised right here?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you just
- Okay
- Right and then maybe you'll
try to make it more fancy
- That was super well improvised.
(piano playing)
- I don't know, maybe you do
No, I don't know about that.
- Yeah right, every
time you play something
really cool you just be like,
do, do, do, do, I don't know
(laughing)
You be killing.
- No, no, no.
A few soloists carry on the tradition of
improvising their own cadenzas,
including pianist Gabriela
Montero and Robert Levin.
Levin tells us, something
spontaneous sounds different
from something that is not,
and the audience benefits
from that in a performance.
Whenever I've played improvised cadenzas,
the audience gets very quiet.
For the first time in most of their lives,
they're at a classical concert
where they don't know
what's going to happen next.
I feel like as a classical musician
I should be able to say yeah,
I can improvise a cadenza.
- You say it's a lost art because
they used to do it all the time.
- They used to, but then now people
just play cadenzas that
are already written out.
- I got the theme, y'all.
- Okay.
- Barney theme song.
- Oh, geez.
- The Barney theme song.
(Twinkle Twinkle Little Star on piano)
- No, no, no, no.
- Twinkle, twinkle.
(piano playing)
(Barney theme song on piano)
- Oh, minor?
- And then the orchestra might go
(humming along with piano playing)
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
- Why do you think improvisation
disappeared from classical
when like they was the
nicest at it in the unit?
- Maybe this is partially the reason why.
- Improvisation?
- Because all the composers wrote
their own versions of cadenzas.
They would write it
out and I think back in
the day it was to facilitate and help
performers that were
just lesser improvisers.
- Guide them through.
- Uh huh, they wanted
to cadenza to be good,
so they wrote one out or several out
and then because they exist performers
would latch onto that and just learn that.
Also during the 19th century
the industrial revolution
created the middle class
and now more people
with disposable income were interested
in music performance and education.
Rather than hiring professional musicians,
middle class households can now purchase
their own instruments
and perform themselves.
Also the growth of
published sheet music gave
more people access to classical music.
The priorities of a lot of classical music
performances, recordings,
concerts, I think it relies
on a certain kind of rigid exactness.
- Yeah, that's intimidating.
- And I think it wasn't always like that.
When you're playing a
piece of baroque music,
even the trills which are
meant to be very spontaneous,
everyone plays it
(piano trill)
like that so everyone will then
but whereas back in the
day they would maybe
(improvised piano trill)
or
The 20th century also brought about
breakthroughs in recording technology.
Now, musical performances
could be captured
and replayed forever and this new reality
lead to the pursuit of perfection
which inevitably involves less
spontaneity and less risk taking.
Recordings of famous works by composers
such as Mozart and
Beethoven became canonized
as museum music with less demand
for improvised performances
or as professor Robin Moore puts it,
spontaneous innovations cannot occur in
music which is intended
to be more a replication
from 1790 than a musical event of today.
Personally, I feel that
improvisation has been making
a sort of comeback into
the classical music world
thanks to many modern composers.
And this has certainly been influencing me
as well as looking toward
other genres like jazz,
flamenco, and folk
music that still embrace
many forms of improvisation.
I think improvisation is
a very valuable practice,
very relevant to music
making, to listening,
and to experience music
in a very spontaneous
and creative way.
For me it's been very fulfilling
to learn how to improvise
in these different styles,
try improvising with the band,
do improvisation experiments
with irregular pulses
and things like that.
So I really do hope to
see more of an emphasis
put on improvisation as a practice
in both formal and informal
music education moving forward.
(soft music)
If I were to give myself
advice I would say
before you do anything else find friends
to explore this with and friends that
can help guide you and jam with you,
because I spent so much
time just on my own
at the piano trying to understand
certain concepts about jamming in general,
but as soon as I started
to play with other
people our jam with
Adam being one of them,
it opened up a different perspective,
a different kind of
understanding about all of this.
- I have my formula of improvisation.
There is inspiration, there's imitation,
and then there's recreation.
The inspiration is what we're inspired by,
it's the template, it's
what catches our attention,
it's what gives us that creative feeling.
My second step is imitation,
learning exactly what
that template is, learning how to play
that template backwards, forward,
learning it like the back of your hand.
This is where the skill portion
comes in, the recreation.
The most important step.
Recreating, adding your flavor to it.
That's like the formula that I use
for improvisation all the time.
(playful music)
Yeah
- Thank you so much for watching
and if you'd like to see more videos
don't forget to subscribe.
(playful music)
- Yeah.